how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
marvel's cinematic universe and we've
had quite a bit of spider-man 3 news
come out over the past
week or so a lot of leaked photos and
videos for spider-man 3 have come out
some revealing an old villain also talks
about
tom holland's future after spider-man 3
spider-man 4
and a new deal between marvel disney and
sony and of course some updates about
andrew garfield and
toby maguire being a part of spider-man
3. so first let's talk about andrew
garfield and toby maguire in spider-man
3 a little bit of an update because i
know everybody is eagerly awaiting some
news about that
now it has been reported that andrew
garfield and toby mcguire have already
filmed or are currently filming
scenes for spider-man 3. however fans
are getting a little discouraged because
we've seen
leaked photos and leaked videos now for
spider-man 3 of tom holland
of zendaya we even got some recent ones
of tom holland and a spider-man suit but
we've seen nothing of the other
spider-man but that does not mean that
they are not going to be in the movie in
fact there's a perfectly good
explanation for this
prior to christmas and the holidays most
of all of the shooting took place
at pinewood studios a studio that is in
doors so if toby maguire and andrew
garfield have been filming for
spider-man 3 that's why we haven't seen
anything yet
and that just makes perfect sense
marvel's trying to avoid any and all
spoilers that the multiverse and
spider-verse are going to be a factor
in spider-man 3. despite all of these
reports from very credible outlets
marvel and sony have yet to come out and
say yep it's a spider-verse film and
they're going to do everything that they
can to avoid any spoilers for this movie
however in the upcoming weeks they are
going to be filming at a different
studio at an
incredibly huge set that is apparently
bigger than
four football fields and it's going to
be outdoors
so if andrew and toby have any scenes
that haven't been filmed yet and are
going to be shot at this
location then we'll definitely be able
to get some leaked photos in the
upcoming weeks
fingers crossed on that one then moving
on to the spider-man
4 news with tom holland it's been
reported by the daily mail that there is
going to be a spider-man 4
with tom holland and of course there is
we knew this before going into
spider-man 3 that tom holland had
two movies left on his contract but we
also knew
that sony and disney had just recently
made a new contract for spider-man in
the marvel cinematic universe and we
knew that this
meant most likely more films tom holland
spider-man
is one of the most successful marvel
characters in the marvel cinematic
universe
and he's extremely important to disney
and marvel and sony as well but it's
also very important to keep him within
the mcu
so of course there's going to be a
spider-man 4 film as is being reported
right now
but there are going to be more films
than just one more
not only will we have a spider-man 4
film but before that we're going to have
a team-up film such as an avengers film
where spider-man participates as well
and in fact we'll most likely have a
spider-man 5 and 6. there is reports
right now going around that marvel sony
and disney are working out
yet another new deal this is no doubt
due to the massive success that
spider-man has had and the massive
talk and hype around spider-man 3 right
now obviously both studios have noticed
how big spider-man
is to the whole entire fan base so of
course they're not just going to let
that go
let spider-man 3 and then the team-up
film be the last films of spider-man
no spider-man is going to be around for
a while and right now there are reports
that we're going to be
seeing spider-man tom holland's peter
parker during his college years
so up until now we've only seen him in
high school but spider-man 4
5 and 6 are rumored to show him in his
college years
this would be extremely cool because
it's not something that we've ever
really seen before
and a lot of people really want to see
tom holland's peter parker be
independent not rely on somebody like
he's relied on tony stark
happy and now apparently in the upcoming
spider-man 3 film
doctor strange a lot of people want to
see him on his own and that's what we
could be getting with the next upcoming
spider-man films with
tom holland and last but not least as i
mentioned we've had plenty of new
spider-man 3 leaked photos come out
one of them showing mysterio in the
background of one of the photos in the
form of
a flyer if we take a look at this leaked
photo we can see
a bunch of flyers on the wall in the
background and this is what they
actually have on them a picture of
mysterio saying i believe and up top
spoke truth now this actually tells us a
little bit about the film
the i believe on the bottom means that
there are people out there who truly do
believe
what mysterio said at the end of far
from home mysterio released a video
via the daily bugle stating that
spider-man was the villain and he was
the one that attacked him
and unleashed the elementals on the
world he then revealed that peter parker
was spider-man
now what's interesting is that at the
top right it says spoke truth
and at the bottom it says i believe now
what this means is that there are indeed
some people out there who don't believe
what mysterio said because if everybody
believed mysterio
why would you make flyers this flyer is
made to make people believe
mysterio was telling the truth it's made
to convince people that peter parker
is bad that he's spider-man and that he
actually attacked and killed mysterio
this is good news for peter because that
means that a lot of people
enough for people to make flyers to try
to convince do believe that he is
innocent and that mysterio was in fact
lying now this could mean that peter
ends up going to court but
ends up being proven innocent there are
talks of matt murdock aka daredevil
showing up but there are talks about him
just showing up as
a lawyer and not actually daredevil it
could be that matt murdock is the one
who proves peter parker innocent
after all he does have a lot of
experience in keeping a secret identity
a secret in fact comicbook.com has
reported that charlie cox who of course
played matt murdock
daredevil in the netflix daredevil
series has already finished filming
for spider-man 3. now he most likely
filmed at pinewood as well
which again is indoors which is most
likely why we haven't seen any leaked
photos of him
even though there were rumors that he
was spotted on set but this confirmation
that charlie cox will be in spider-man 3
as matt murdock combined with these
posters
do lead me to believe that at some point
in time peter parker might go to trial
and matt murdock will defend him and get
him proven innocent
then people are going to be very upset
about that because they believe mysterio
and that's when these flyers will come
into play
also touching on mysterio there has been
reports that spider-man is going to be
facing the original sinister 6 and
spider-man 3.
mysterio is a part of that original
sinister six
it's sandman vulture doctor octopus
electro craven the hunter and mysterio
now it's already reported that sand man
and doctor octopus from the sam
raimi spider-man universes will be
coming into play in spider-man 3.
and of course it's been reported that
jamie foxx's electro from the amazing
spider-man universe will be in
spider-man 3 as well
then vulture already exists within our
main spider-man universe right now and
it's been rumored that craven is going
to be one of the villains of spider-man
3 for a very long time now so we
essentially have the original sinister
six with the exception of mysterio
because he's believed to be dead but i
actually don't think he's dead and i do
believe he'll be returning
to join the sinister six to face off
against peter parker and i actually
think this is going to be a very pivotal
moment for peter parker and spider-man
moving forward in future films because
if people see mysterio
out in the open specifically fighting
against spider-man
of course they'll know that mysterio
isn't actually dead and peter parker
didn't actually kill him therefore all
of the people who may not believe that
spider-man is good
could have a change of heart since
clearly mysterio had been lying and that
could
clear peter parker's name once and for
all which is something that we do need
moving forward because if we are going
to explore peter parker's story even
further and he's going to just
exist in the world going to college
having a job etc he can't be a wanted
man the entire time so his name will
have to be made clean
something that i do believe will happen
in spider-man 3 whether that's mysterio
returning or not
so a lot of big things happening within
the spider-man
universe not just with spider-man 3 but
future spider-man films as well
again they're going to start shooting at
a different insanely huge studio
outside within the upcoming week so
hopefully we get some new
leaked photos relatively soon so be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest spider-man 3 news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof you